[Music]
[Applause]
get ready for the first ever streaming
exclusive NFL game in history NFL
holiday exclusive on peacock it'll be
the Buffalo Bills they face the Chargers
in Los Angeles you can uh stream it live
this Saturday at 7:30 p.m. Eastern
exclusively on peacock and uh part of
the broadcast team with Mike too it'll
be Chris Collinsworth just inducted into
the sports broadcasting Hall of Fame and
a man who once raced a
horse who by the way whose idea was it
when you were with the Bengals that what
was that 1983 that you raced a horse I
actually did it twice if you can believe
that so a guy named Andy Ferman do you
remember
Andy so I was doing the radio by the way
you read commercials way better than I
ever did I I got so nervous doing that I
hated doing that it was it was awful so
uh Mike Bagley who's a great buddy of
mine who sets all the morning odds for
the Kentucky Derby has for 50 years he's
gonna do this will be his 50th year of
doing that they've only had 150 so he's
he's done a third of them out there but
Andy was out there and he was like the
GM of Turfway Park and and Turfway you
know they had those horses out there and
da da da we were talking about I even
know like some they were giving me heat
and I was going oh man I could outrun
these horses you guys have a Turfway
Park out here you know one of those kind
of conversations that that we all have
and Andy went oh really oh you think you
could outrun one of the horses and I
said absolutely so they set up a date
with or I'm racing Mr hurry Mr hurry had
run 117 times in his career had one win
to show for it and it's history right so
they're trying to give Mr hurry his
second win so they come out and I go
well Andy you got to set up something
and goes you know so I gotta come out of
the gates and the the dirt is like you
know it's like running on the beach you
can't run on that stuff and he said
don't worry about it I'll have like a
wooden track made up it'll be a fair
fight it'll be you know this whole thing
so I come out and I get a
tuxedo the whole with a cane you know
and I'm I'm I've got like this back in
my single days I get two girls dressed
up in tuxedo things they come pulling up
out on the the track I come out like one
of those big- time wrestlers you know I
love wrestling when I was a kid and I'm
waving to the crowd biggest crowd they
ever had at Turfway park it was just out
of control people are screaming I come
out I'd get out of my tuxedo they throw
me into Starting Gate and Andy had laid
out a piece of carpet that ran 40 yards
of this race I mean you talking it was
impossible to run on the sand but even
worse than try to run on the carpet so I
tried to get a little Head Start you
know how they have the springloaded
gates that that open that's how you get
out of the gate so I figured if I just
held on to that gate it would just throw
my butt out of there so I hold on to the
thing of the gate and it goes it throw
I'm stumbly out the gate I can barely
run on this carpet by the time I get to
the Finish Line Mr is already around the
first turn and heading down the back it
was the worst mess of all time but I
think I got a couple hundred bucks so it
was worth it but then there was a
rematch well then then then they had
River Downs across the way they wanted
to do one too and that was more fair
because we raced on the turf and and so
what they did was they they came out and
so I got just the normal start and and
that was closer because then the course
had to start from scratch and it came
down to really a photo finish and I
don't know how they do this but they
they doctored the photo finish a little
bit to make it look like a tie when I
really lost by a little bit I didn't
think it was possible for me to lose by
a nose but I lost by they redrew that
line a little bit so it looked like a
tie it was a better better story then we
were just talking about you know could
you see a scenario where Kirby Smart
would leave Georgia maybe coach the
Atlanta Falcons I said I can't imagine
let's say
hypothetical but given today's climate
in college football with nil and
transfer portal and
everything would you rather coach
Georgia or would you rather coach the
Atlanta Falcons if you're Kirby Smart if
you had the
opportunity well since Georgia is a
longtime rival of my University of
Florida I would be just fine with him
leaving and going to National Football
League he's done an incredible job there
I I do think college football we we
still don't know what it's going to be
right I mean nobody really understands
where this is going everybody that I've
talked to seems to think it's going to
end up like the NFL it's going to be the
you know AFC and the NFC we're gonna
have the big 10 and the SEC and pretty
soon everybody's going to pile into
those two conferences and and and go get
it but I do think for Kirby it's an
opportunity right it's an opportunity go
back to all the alums at the University
of Georgia and go look this is going to
come down to one thing here in the
future who has the most money to spend
on these players and my coaches and do
you want me here because I got used to
winning right I'm used to winning a lot
of football games here at Georgia so if
we can come up with pick a number
whatever it is these days $50 million
for nil money and then I I'd much rather
stay here but if it were not and I'm
going to end up getting beat by
Vanderbilt because they have more money
I'm just throwing a name out there then
I would rather go to the NF so I think
it's an opportunity for him to negotiate
which all things are it's Chris
Collinsworth it'll be Sunday Night
Football on Saturday night with Mike too
the Chargers and bills exclusively on
peacock what would it take for Patrick
momes to be labeled the greatest
quarterback of all time by
you interesting uh
well he's on his way right I mean he
definitely has the
opportunity um because of what he's done
so early in his career Tom Brady
is pretty lofty standard uh to be able
to do that and I think Tom going to
Tampa and winning another one set the
bar really high you know it really did
and I don't know how long Andy Reid's
going to coach but that'll be a factor
when he has to switch coaches and go
into another system but I still think he
has a chance I I I I think he is can do
some really magical things um it's been
kind of interesting watching him the
last few weeks so you can see the
frustration level really beginning to
rise and I you can't really blame him I
mean some of those plays you know
haven't been quite as good and and
really with Travis Kelce you know how
long can Travis Kelce maintain the level
where he's been playing so there are
going to be adjustments i i i Tyreek
hill was a big loss for that uh
franchise and he's proving it you know
in Miami but can you say best to ever
play the position without factoring in
the number of Super Bowls you
win he'd have to get close you know I
think he'd have to he doesn't
necessarily have to get seven eight
whatever the case may be but he'd have
to win at least five and yeah but I I do
he's a fabulous player I mean he just he
just is he just but we always hear Aaron
roders is the most talented to play the
position not the best quarterback but
the most
talented depends on which day of the
week it was he was the best quarterback
sometimes and and you know you could
look at his MVPs and the things that he
did so I I think I know where you're
going and I go this way a long ways too
as somebody who lost two Super Bowls I
don't think it should all be that Kenny
Anderson was unbelievable the Super Bowl
we lost he played a great game the rest
of us stunk it up and made mistakes and
you know so should he be punished
because he didn't win that Super Bowl
when he also won four passing titles you
know so that it's not all about Super
Bowls but I do think to some extent he'd
have to get close I I would say at least
five Michael Parsons has a podcast and
uh he was critical of the media waiting
for the Cowboys to lose like we took joy
in the Cowboys
losing uh they do get more credit than
they deserve they get more blame than
they deserve but at the end of the day
they're the most popular the most
valuable franchise there but what what
do you think we're missing when it comes
to this cowboy team that their identity
is what
um it's sort of like the the old fast
break Lakers you know that that they
have to play their kind of game and um
the Buffalo Bills really got after them
running the ball it was stunning to
watch how their inability to just stop
the run in that game the bills you know
we've got them this week they had no
intention at all of it just being a a
purely running game but they had their
starters out of the game game you know
early in the fourth quarter so I if if
you can't play that kind of football you
know San Francisco can play a physical
brand of football right Baltimore can
play a physical brand of football um
Philadelphia can certainly play that
style I do think the question's going to
be do they have an Achilles heel do they
have an issue when somebody just lines
up and you know they they they lost Zach
Martin in the game they've had some
injuries on the defensive line they
drafted in the first round a defensive
tackle which I almost would have never
believed the Cowboys would just to stop
the run but that really he hasn't had
much impact at all uh on stopping the
run so when it comes right down to it is
everything going to be a shoot out no we
know come playoff time there's going to
be some ugliness to the whole thing and
the Cowboys have to prove they can win
that
style you got the Chargers in the bills
on Saturday night on peacock but I'm
looking at the Chargers job there's
going to be some vacancies we know that
I don't know how many but where how
desirable is that charger's job I think
it's the number one job I I I really do
it's a um because you have the
quarterback you know once you have the
quarterback then then you're you got a
chance because you can build everything
else around it and Justin Herbert is of
of that quality that that he you know he
can win a Super Bowl I mean you know
that so you eliminate the hardest part
of taking over a job and you're living
in La a lot of people want to live in LA
and pay a lot in the taxes I don't know
why but that's good good for
them I'm just a joke don't don't just a
joke and my son's out there I wear them
out all the time yeah so but I I do
think and you're going to get turn over
at the receiver position out there
they've got a good player and Slater
playing left tackle you've got good
pressure guys on the outside there's no
reason I can't give you the reason that
the Chargers continue to struggle to to
get into contention and viy for a
championship I I honestly cannot do it
so I I don't know where they're going if
I gave you the Niners or the
field who would you
take you know what makes me hesitate I I
think the Niners are a deserving
favorite I really do but the NFC in
general has not been what the AFC has
been this year it just hasn't been at
that level so if you're if you're
looking at the AFC and and let's take a
team let's take Baltimore you know just
slugging their way through that division
alone is hard enough and then you're
going to have to slug your way through
good teams in the playoffs I mean when
the B we're talking about the Buffalo
Bills trying to get in as a seventh seed
think about that I mean trying to get in
as a ninth or whatever right now it's
unbelievable so when you slug your way
through whatever it is the AFC um and
we've seen San Francisco not struggle at
all with Dallas or Philadelphia when
they played are they to be as battle
tested come that last game um that
you're assuming they're going to get to
so I I'm going to say I would take the
field as of right now what do you do if
you're Mike tomman with George Pickins
who decided he didn't want to block on a
play near the Gold Line and the guy he
was supposed to be blocking ended up
making the tackle and he said you know I
I didn't want to get hurt I didn't want
somebody to roll up on
me all right I'm GNA I'm going to take
it from the wide receiver position first
okay remember Pete Johnson used to play
for us in Cincinnati big man I love
Pete's one of my favorite guys he's
great player he was he came he came in
for the freeze bowl game and and we were
all putting on panty hoose that's we had
no nobody had an answer for how to keep
warm it was 59 below zero he Pete comes
in and he's Fring around the locker room
and those panty hoose and he said how'd
I look I said you look fat like you
always do what are you talking about but
anyway Pete Pete
Pete would come and and Pete I you know
and so I'm trying to block for Pete
downfield and Pete never made a cut you
know he just would run over whatever was
in his way whether it was me or the
defensive guy and he was a great player
and but I mean I got hurt a couple of
times trying to to block for for Pete so
there is some legitimacy to what he said
you know there is some danger of getting
hurt back there that being
said it doesn't fit the Steelers right
it doesn't fit Mike Tomlin they're
they're there and I know all of us
receiver types are divas and all that
kind of stuff but it just doesn't there
seems to be something different with
that team and maybe that's a fraction of
it you know maybe just the fact that
everybody isn't all in to kill and do
anything for the Pittsburgh Steelers on
every play I just can't imagine it sits
very well in Pittsburgh yeah I know well
they they got rid of their offensive
coordinator that didn't help uh should
Mike Tomlin be feeling some
heat nope I I mean it's a remarkable run
I I think if you put Mike Tomlin on the
open market there are teams that weren't
even considering firing their head coach
that would consider firing their head
coach to give Mike Tomlin I I I think
he's a remarkable coach his record
speaks for itself he's won a Super Bowl
he's never had a losing year and if I
had to bet even though they've got a
tough schedule I figured some way that
he's not going to have a losing year
this year he's probably the brightest of
the coaches that we talk to as far as
being not just the X's and O's and the
individual time that he spends with the
individual players but he's just such a
natural motivator of men you know he
really is he could be anything he could
be president of the United States He
Could Be commissioner of the league he
could his opinions are like so spot-on
whenever there's controversy in the
league and you ask him about it it's
just like boom boom and it's so logical
I I he would
be never in my lifetime would I consider
firing that guy good to talk to you have
fun on Saturday night we appreciate your
time as always Chris see DP good talking
to you bu that's Chris Collinsworth
he'll be there with Mike too it's Bill's
Chargers Saturday night exclusively on
peacock